NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY THE
NEWBORN IDENTITY.
BABIES ARE CRAFTY LIKE ICE IS
COLD.
YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT'S GOING THROUGH THEIR
[BLEEP] HEAD.
WHEN THEY GO YOU THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO GA.
YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING TO SPIT
UP ON THEIR SHIRT, THEY [BLEEP]
UP THEIR BACK.
WE FOUND SOME SHALL WE
SAY HORRIBLE BABY PHOTOS ON THE
SCOUT'S CHEAT SHEET BLOG.
FOR 250 POINTS I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME
WHAT EACH BABY IS THINKING.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE.
ADORABLE.
HE LIED.
JUSTIN.
>> IT APPEARS AS THOUGH I'VE
DEFICATED IN MY PANTS.
>> MARY LYNN.
>> AFGHANISTAN.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
[LAUGHTER]
JON DALY.
>> GO FOR THE BODY ROCK, YOU GOT
TO KILL THE BODY.
[CROWD CHEERING]
>> ALL RIGHT.
LOOK AT THESE TWO OBVIOUSLY
HUMAN CHILDREN.
>> HA HA HA HA.
>> WHAT'S THIS COMEDY TROUPE
THINKING ABOUT.
MARY LYNN.
>> OUR DAD IS DAVE COULIER. OUR
MOM IS A LEMUR.
>> JUSTIN.
>> WE WERE MADE IN JIM HENSON'S
WORKSHOP.
>> JON DALY.
>> PSST. HEY, ME, THE BABY ON
THE LEFT.
GET ME AWAY FROM THIS
DEAD-EYED MONSTER.
>> I LIKE THE BABY REFERS TO
ITSELF AS THE BABY ON THE LEFT.
IN THE PICTURE, COME ON.
HE WOULD PROBABLY BE ON THE
RIGHT TO HIMSELF, I GET IT.
THIS KID PROBABLY GREW UP JUST
LIKE THIS.
>> HA HA HA HA.
>> MARY LYNN.
>> I'M NOT ALLERGIC TO PEANUTS,
PEANUTS ARE ALLERGIC TO ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JUSTIN.
>> YOUR MOVE, MR. BOND.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THIS WEE WAIF RIGHT HERE.
JON.
>> WUZZUP?
>> HE'S GIVING ME THE CREEPS.
>> LAST ONE. THIS SAD PRINCE
AND/OR PRINCESS.
>> HE BLOCKED ME ON INSTAGRAM.
>> IRL CRYING BABY EMOJI.
>> I MUST HAVE BEEN REALLY
WASTED.
I MUST HAVE LEFT MY CREDIT CARD
AT BENNIGAN'S.
>> JON DALY.
>> MY MOLLY HASN'T KICKED IN
YET.